llega la información económica france24
y en el estudio me acompaña mi compañera
daniela blandón para discutirla daniela
buenas noches en cuba hay reacciones al
anuncio del gobierno que no recibirá
dólares o la valentina buenas noches
primero recordemos cómo fue ese anuncio
pues desde el próximo 21 de junio el
gobierno de la isla dejará temporalmente
de aceptar ingresos en dólares en
efectivo como represalia por el bloqueo
de eeuu algunos lo ven como un intento
de controlar el precio del dólar en el
mercado ilegal que se ha más que
duplicado frente a los 24 pesos cubanos
que cuesta el oficial desde que la isla
unificó su tipo de cambio en enero
analistas deben al euro por ejemplo como
el principal candidato para reemplazar a
esta divisa
pero yo creo que el aula familia cubana
de una u otra forma particular se con
eso es decir va a empezar entonces en
vez de mandar dólares va a mandar euros
y va a tratar de utilizar los mecanismos
que existen todavía en europa de
transferencias monetarias cambiamos de
tema porque la economía es la
protagonista de la reunión del g7 en
reino unido- y valentina inició este
viernes la primera reunión presencial de
las siete economías más poderosas desde
que inició la pandemia y son canadá
francia alemania italia japón reino
unido y eeuu el plato fuerte económico
promete ser el impuesto global a las
multinacionales del 15 por ciento por lo
menos que propuso la casa blanca y que
ya fue avalado por los ministros de
finanzas en una reunión previa pero
también hubo un llamado de parte del
grupo benéfico oxfam para que se avance
en las conversaciones sobre la polémica
iniciativa de liberar las patentes de
las vacunas la última palabra de todas
maneras la tiene la organización mundial
del comercio en lo que sí parecen estar
en sintonía sus países es en que van a
mantener los estímulos a sus economías
mientras dure la crisis daniela y ahora
hablamos de méxico uno de los países más
golpeados por la pandemia y es que esta
nación le falta recuperar medio millón
de empleos sí señora de la oficina de
estadística de este país informó que en
mayo la economía recobró más de 38 mil
empleos formales
después de casi perder 280 mil plazas
laborales sólo en diciembre méxico
comenzó a recuperarse en enero y desde
entonces ha venido recobrando estos
puestos de trabajo sin embargo como
vemos en el gráfico la de mayo fue la
cifra más baja desde el comienzo de año
pero pese al aumento del empleo en los
últimos meses todavía quedan por
recuperar como usted lo decía más de 500
mil puestos de trabajo formal esto para
alcanzar 20,6 millones de empleos que
había en febrero de 2020 es decir antes
de la pandemia pues de méxico pasamos a
líbano las farmacias cerraron sus
puertas en este país esto hace parte de
una huelga de dos días por la grave
escasez de medicamentos en un país al
que la crisis no le da tregua en las
farmacias falta de todo valentina desde
medicina para enfermedades crónica
hasta leche de fórmula para bebés la
situación es tal que los hospitales de
este pequeño país de medio oriente ya
dijeron que la próxima semana podrían
verse obligados a suspender los
tratamientos de diálisis renal porque no
hay suministros médicos
álvaro también se unieron los
motociclistas quienes se apostaron
frente a las estaciones de servicio para
protestar por la falta de combustible
pues que también amenaza con dejar sin
luz a la mayoría de los libaneses que
dependen de generadores eléctricos
la situación ya no es soportable las
farmacias están cerradas en medicinas no
hay leche para bebés no esconden para
que quiten los subsidios las gasolineras
están cerradas no hay nada ya black
vamos con los indicadores económicos de
la jornada la bolsa de nueva york que
cerró la semana mixta a pesar de un dato
alto de inflación que el mercado ya daba
por descontado las acciones europeas
también se están moviendo en terrenos
históricos gracias en parte a que
confían en que los principales bancos
centrales van a mantener sus estímulos y
en américa latina se destacó la bolsa de
méxico que subió más del 15 por ciento
en la semana
daniela y la cifra del día para
finalizar 1,6 millones de euros
valentina pues mire estas la asignación
anual que debería recibir desde
diciembre
la princesa amalia ella es la heredera
al trono de países bajos y cuando cumpla
18 años le van a dar este dinero pero
decidió este viernes renunciar a él en
medio de la polémica que ha suscitado
por considerarse excesivo de ese total
300 mil euros corresponden al salario y
1,3 millones a gastos personales hasta
que termine sus estudios
daniela muchas gracias por este análisis
toda la ampliación económica ustedes
gracias por su sintonía volvemos en
breve con más noticias
[Música]